hello and welcome to episode two of
buying and selling and free to playay
RuneScape uh so last episode we ended up
with about
127k and yeah we're going to see what we
can go from here so we're going to start
off uh by just checking our history here
we did a couple great flips with admin
plate bodies like those are awesome so
we're going to continue trying to do a
couple more of those and uh pick a
couple new items going forward but yeah
we're going to start with the adant
plate legs just cuz they had such
massive margin I mean each one we sold
last episode we were making
almost about 15K at least uh so we're
going to go buy 10 more of those and um
we're going to try try to sell our
shears which seem kind of stupid now uh
but yeah and I'm just going to find
another item to put in here so friend
you watched episode one I'm glad you
tuned in you may have noticed my mic is
pretty awful and uh it's cuz I found in
my closet I had to duct tape it together
I I originally bought it at Walmart just
because it lit up so obviously you can
tell by that the mic should not be too
good uh but yeah we're going to mess
around with the settings I notic the
audio was a bit low in the last episode
so we're just going to wait for these
Adam plate Bo to buy I really do not
care about the shears but we're just
going to find one more item to put in
there and I will be right
back all right uh so we managed to buy
eight of the adamant plate legs G and uh
we already sold five of them uh so we
bought them all for about
83k well not quite cuz we didn't buy
them all but um we did sell five of them
for 20K so that's 100K right there plus
we still have the three left over uh
which we're going to try to sell for 20K
each as well so each one we're making 12
13k so still that's very very good for
freet to-play
items so yeah we're going to uh put that
in offer in and then we're going to try
another one we're going to try the
mythal plate legs Jesus this time uh for
any of you wondering I did check the
margin ahead of time I'm not just
totally guessing uh but at the same time
not 100% sure they're going to buy for
this price so it's always kind of a
surprise when they
do and yeah so we're going to just fill
the offer slot so we're going to try put
another offer for admin PL legs just
because they've been doing so well and
we're going to try to sell off the last
three we have already so yeah we'll just
be wait a couple hours and we'll see how
many of these have bought we'll get rid
of this Year's offer
cuz kind of redundant now uh yeah so
I'll be back when a couple of these have
bought and
sold all right uh so we managed to buy
eight of the mythro play legs so we
bought the eight for about 8K I think
yeah 8K and we sold them for 14 C that
was really quick so 6K profit on each
one making about 40 50k on the myal
plate legs we sold the three Adam and
play legs we had already so that's
another 12 13k on each one of
those and on top of that we actually
bought 12 more of the Adent play legs so
we're just going to sell them back for
20K why not I mean we're just prepare
for me to run this item to the ground so
we'll just keep doing that so those sold
we'll get about 240k out of that making
about 150k I mean that's so crazy for
how small a cash stack I have so these
trimmed pieces of armor great so coming
up here uh you might notice that I check
the margin just manually uh it's cuz
it's not always accurate on the OS budy
exchange and uh I just wanted to see
because these don't buy and sell that
frequently uh so I checked it and I did
lose 12K checking it uh so I'll have to
buy at least a couple of these to get my
money back so it's a bit of a gamble but
I think it's going to pay off for this
one cuz there's 3500 per piece and it's
a little crazy I'm not going to buy
these but you get the idea I will make
my money back and more just by checking
accurately cuz otherwise I might have
put in uh eight or seven or 9k which I
would have been realistically losing
some of my profit there so it's probably
going to work in this case so yeah I
will just check back when uh some of
these are bought okay so the margins
unfortunately crashed on both the pl
legs that I were
buying which is not too bad actually in
the grand scheme of things I did
actually lose a clip here so I'm just
going to piece this together for you so
we did manage to buy some of the mythal
play
legs about eight of them and we did sell
a couple of them back for pretty hefty
profit of
about see 6 or 7K
each unfortunately on the adamant plate
legs we actually lost a bit of money but
a 1K loss on each one uh that being said
we the margin's so low now it's about it
was 3,000 or 4,000 that I could buy them
for so we will hopefully still make some
money on this item it's just changed so
this would be a good opportunity to buy
some and I probably will I just want to
sell off the items I have just to see
how much cash I have to work with so
I'll just check back in on when these
have
sold okay so we have a couple offers
still going here uh we're still flipping
the mythal plate legs for solid chunk
cash seven or 8K in each one so we're
going to keep that going uh one thing I
missed to record was the admin plate
legs I had left I did sell for 6K each
so I had to lower it a little bit more
probably ended up breaking even on item
because you may have noticed on the
other clip I actually managed to buy one
for just 2100 so we'll probably broke
even uh but we're going to leave it for
a little while we're just going to buy a
couple of these blue wizard hats in the
meantime
just just have our offer slots filled I
don't think this is going to be very
good so we sold off our mythal play legs
uh we had to reduce the selling price uh
because it it did drop again
so reduced it to about
8K so we're going to make about on the
whole transaction of 15 play legs we'll
make about 30
40K still really good still can't
complain too much uh in the meantime I
did try buying and selling some pure
Essence which is pretty safe uh but it
does take a long time like the buying
limit is I think 20,000 it can take the
entire day to buy and sell the full
amount so it's kind of debatable if it's
worth it I'm just going to be leaving
for a day or two so it might be worth it
just to keep the offer in there uh
because it's consistent and safe uh and
on top of that we also bought some
mythal full Helm G's just to give them a
shot uh we're hoping to make about 10K
on each one of those uh and we'll just
leave that in while we're gone uh so
we're going to buy about I think we're
going to buy 20,000 pure Essence and and
flip them for one GP on each one so
that'll be about 20K we'll make on the
pure Essence 20K hopefully making on the
the full Helms and uh we'll just find
one more item to put in
here it takes me a little while to find
one just because my two goto items have
crashed a bit so what we're going to do
here is uh we're actually going to check
OS body uh for kind of the lowest
selling rate they've been going for in
the last little while this is just so
that when I'm away for my one day
vacation I won't buy them at a higher
price than they normally are at so what
we're going to do is just bring up OS
buddy uh put an Adent PL legs G now I
should have probably looked back at the
quarter but I just look back at the
month so you can see it was highest it
was around 15 16k and on average it's
around 7 to 8,000 and you can actually
see pretty accurately what the Buy price
is in the top corner there
so we're going to put in a price of
about 7700 we'll leave it in so now if
it does buy we'll most likely be able to
sell it for more if we just checked
checked it and for say it came up with
like a 12K or something and we just left
it in it could very well have gone down
as as easily it could have gone up so it
would been a lot riskier so we might not
buy any at this price point but we might
as well try uh it's just time waste
otherwise so I will be checking back on
these flips in about 24 hours
all right so we've uh sold the mythal
full Helm for about 10K profit on each
one so 20K there uh the pure Essences
we've managed to buy and sell them all
one GP profit on each Essence so 20K on
that and uh we're kind of working on
selling off these adant plate legs I'm
probably going to make 4k on these ones
uh but unfortunately the margin has
lowered a bit on those but that's okay
so we're going to just try to sell these
off but I think that's where we're going
to end the the episode I'm going to try
to keep this one a little bit shorter
between maybe 8 and 9 minutes instead of
like
14 yeah so after we've sold everything
you should go for about 7K each so
another 50 or something K there we
should have about 375k uh so we're doing
quite well and I'm pretty happy with the
progress so far and um so I actually
have some more Clips already that I'm
going to put in next episode so it
shouldn't take too long for next one and
uh yeah hopefully we can get up to a
mill pretty soon all right well see you
guys next time
[Music]